[Music]
hey guys tonight as promised HP unveiled
the long-awaited premiere date of game
during season 8 and the new teaser the
crypts of NFL delivers their hints of
things to come for how stark and
confirms that season 8 will hit our TV
screen starting on April 14th 2019 it's
just a teaser this sequence will not be
in season 8
but nonetheless it's quite important if
our shadows fates of some main
characters such as Jon Snow surviving
the events of game grumps it also seems
to be foreshadowing some main events
there yet to come such as Starks in the
living room ceiling north rather than
south after they lose battle for
Winterfell against the night king and
much much more these wrinkles John
passing his matters leanness and its
ankles Ned statues with their voiceover
since the passing her mother's cat
statue with cats voiceover followed by
Arya all three met in the middle and
they're confronted by statues at
themselves it's very interesting that
bran is not there
Arya statue is holding the needle since
it's looking like the Lady of Winterfell
and John age that she bears is now
signature scar ultra turn around and the
coldness rolls over leonis fetter John
an aria Joe their swords long Chloe
needle and their Dez the season 8
premiere date April 14th another
interesting thing to me is that this
exactly living in three dead members of
House Stark are chosen for this teaser
it could have been robbed so Rick
instead shooter instead of cats or
Leanna's but it wasn't it was Ned's
leonis and cats it could have been bran
stark in this theater instead of one of
these three but it wasn't it was John
sense and Arya and when you look at it
it makes perfect sense
here we have six characters three dead
three alive but it's actual three in
total in other words it said over and
over that John looks and acts like Ned
Stark Arya looks the next likely Anna
Sansa looks the next flick at another
interesting thing here is the fetter now
it being dreams Fedder doesn't mean it's
brain Stark's vision because remember
this sequence will not be the part of
the final season
it's just made up for this theater in
this teaser only however this same
Ferrer has been seen multiple times
throughout the series in the fourth
episode of the fifth season while
visiting the stark family Krebbs beside
relighting the candle sense also picks
up the feather of the floor which is the
same fetter that Robert Baratheon placed
in the hand of a statue of Liana in the
very first episode of the series
which is the same Feder with seen this
teaser does it mean something it could
be seen as a supporting evidence of a
theory I'm going to talk about in a
minute the theory about Johnson learning
the truth in the crypts of inner feltro
here an object Ned led for John back to
the teaser as already said keep in mind
that it's not an actual footage from an
episode but just something made up
specifically for the teaser this may not
be an actual footage of the final season
but make no mistake there's a lot of her
shadows happening it's a very well-done
teaser but it left fans terrified about
what it might be for sharing some
believe it's for sharing sense of
becoming the queen and Arie and John
will die protecting her udders claims
foreshadowing that brain is the only
Stark hoster eyes since brain doesn't
have stature how I see it is that these
statues of Johnson scenario are
directional statues after their death
however not all of them will die in
season eight and not all these statues
will be seen during season eight just
take a look at John statue for a second
if this teaser foreshadow something is
the Johnston survive the game turns and
live until the very old age notice how
John only statue looks aged too old in
my opinion John statue doesn't for
shadow him dying in the final season as
some would assume but just the opposite
if our share of just surviving the
events of game interest and living for
many many more years which comes as a
good news on the other side are incense
Saluki under statues which might
foreshadow that their fates are sealed
and they won't survive the final season
or at least not long after now let's see
how this teaser might be for sharing
another major event a response it's now
that episode 3 of season 8 we'll see an
epic battle between the living and the
dead for Winterfell and the living
bellows most feldheim interval will be
led burned down and in ruins
most of us thought the living would then
retreat south to form a new line of
defense at other formidable castles such
as the area or even King's Landing but
this teaser might be hinting just the
opposite to me it seems the stars and
living might retreat north to the world
rather than south after they lose the
battle from interval but how you might
ask they would not make it 10 feet past
the Winterfell gates not to mention all
the way to the wall with the night Kings
armies running it you might be wrong
because there are vases we learn from
mr. lewin in season 1 they're hidden
passageways built so the Lords of
Winterfell could escape in emergency and
mr. Lowen actually offered the theand to
use it to escape winter fell and join
the Nights Watch when Ramsey came that
hidden passage might be this tunnel is
passing through the question that comes
to mind is why the crypts of NFL are so
prominently featured while the show
throw this teaser yes it's very
important for stars as it contains the
tombs of the members of House Stark
but there must be more than that
especially with it being so prominently
featured in this teaser what does it
mean for the final season and what
importance does he hold in the States
very tech hoes John's recurring dreams
about something calling him in the
credits below Winterfell that he has in
the books in the very first novel in the
Song of Ice and Fire well at Castle
black Jon Snow tell Sam that he
sometimes dreams of the crypts Jon says
that he walks deeper in the crypts but
it's afraid of what he will find within
them and awakens every time the credits
become too dark John says the same that
he knows he has to go down there but he
doesn't want to as he is afraid of what
might be waiting for him it's quite a
popular theory that Jon will learn the
truth behind his parentage in-game Jonas
is basically preparing the ground for it
to take place in the crypts of NFL in
the steerer Ned he dragged her scar upon
the Winterfell with intention for Jon to
find it someday and he carried in John's
own tomb basically net will fulfill his
last promise he's ever given he will
tell Jon Snow who its mother and father
are although not literally sure bran
could share what he saw in his vision or
Howland Reed could telling the truth but
the only way for the revelation to have
its full effect is for Jon to discover
tans own which brings us to the crypts
of NFL the crypts have been included in
both the books on the show which along
with all the scenes that took place over
there in the show and with all Josh
dreams and visions about it in the books
has led many people to believe that
there's something about them of high
significance to the upcoming plot the
crypts are located below meaner fell and
it contained the tombs of the members of
House Stark are massive in the larger
than the entire Castle complex about
ground and not only would it be a
perfect place to hide something just
because it's huge but it's also the last
place someone will look for another
reason why someone would hide something
so important in the crypts is because
there are not many people visiting there
are only a very few people that are
visiting the grips which the scene from
the fourth episode of the fifth season
is confirming as we can see while
visiting the stark family crypt viscera
lighting the candle sense also picks up
the feather of the floor which is the
same favorite Robert Baratheon placed in
the hand of statue of Lee and I'm the
very first episode of the series there's
most certainly a high possibility that
Ned took something from Tower of joy
something related to the truth about
Jon's parentage and here it encrypts
Rhaegar scarp might be one of if not the
only object that Rhaegar might have left
in the Tower of joy with his blood Lena
Starr not only did lianna enjoy
listening Rhaegar playing her but he
also most likely did not carries her
foul marching in the war
there's also one fact that is going
favor to this theory which is there has
not been mentioned in regular scarp
during or after Robert's rebellion he
might be implying that Rhaegar beside
leaving his best friend and greatest
fighter the Seven Kingdoms has ever seen
to protect Vienna and their unborn son
Rhaegar also most likely let his Harvey
Liana in the Tower of joy as a symbol
for Leonov his love towards her and
promised to return however upon rakers
death during the battle the Trident end
up only Anna's death in the hands of
Nanda the Tower of joy it's possible
that Knight took Reger's harp along with
Lena's corpse and hid it somewhere in
the crypts of NFL if naturally did high
drag or sharp underman of elven
intention for john to find it someday
I'll place my bet on - no one knew
existed Jon Snow stone as the best Sir
John doesn't get a tomb on his own in
the crypts so Ned would have had one
made for Johnny secret pinup that Ned
had his empty tomb already prepared
before his death in fact we're told that
are numerous empty and symptoms repaired
for not only Ned but also for his
children in the book John often dreams
of the crypts of inner fell in which he
sees statues of kings of in here
watching him as he passes them John sees
the stone star Kings eyes following him
as they tell him he doesn't belong there
which could imply that Johnny's in fact
already given a place
additionally in it has a similar dreams
of the crypts as John which could be a
hint that his angered the Old Kings of
in her by giving John a place even
though he's not a stark but rather a
Targaryen
I believe that tomb was prepared for
joining the Winterfell crypts hidden
away in the lower levels in side will be
razor-sharp and the crown of intros this
Rhaegar led only in his lap at a tourney
at Harrenhal when he crowned her a queen
of love and beauty in case you're
wondering did not let have to keep
John's parentage a secret as he promised
to his sister or did Ned had the
stonemason killed after this one made a
tombstone for John the answer is no in
fact the answer lies in a conversation
between timing and are in season 2
episode 7 in that scene not knowing who
are actually is believing she's the
daughter of Snow Maiden from the north
timing was surprised when she told him
that her alleged stonemason father
taught her how to read having said he
was a well-read stonemason can't say
I've ever met a literate stonemason
there is no literate stonemason and Ned
did not take any risk by making just on
his own tune with his true name Aegon
Targaryen on it in conclusion the crypts
have been included in both the books and
the show which along with all the scenes
that took place over there in the show
and we told judge dreams and visions
about it in the books give us a reason
to believe it to play a major role in
huge revelation for John
how awesome would it be if Ned turns out
to be the one to reveal John the truth
Ned Stark is Oathkeeper he's a man of
his word
and if he says he'll do something he'll
do it and that's why I believe Ned
Villefort failed les promises that were
given and it will talk with John about
his matter and that will reveal the
truth to Jon Snow through a letter that
is hidden in John's ticker tomb it his
real name written on it inside it will
be rehgar pan Lena's crown with roses
revealing to John his show parentage or
at least that's how I like to see it
this teaser could be foreshadowing many
things but in my opinion foreshadow just
one for sure justice arrives the game of
Thrones and rules or just lives until
the very old age as age John is that you
seems to be hinting and as always I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]